selbst der nebel über der weichsel
leuchtet in weiß und rot
das sind polens nationalfarben kunden
marschieren männer keine veteran sondern
junge leute für die unabhängigkeit so
als ob sie noch errungen werden müsste
dazu skandieren sie gott ehre vaterland
die straßen von warschau gehören den
nationalisten aber nur für diesen tag
dieser marsch erinnert an den tag im
jahre 1918 als polen endlich wieder
nation sein durfte lang allzu lang war
polen spielball fremder mächte opfer
deutschen größenwahns ein satellit der
kommunistischen sowjetunion und jetzt
mitten in einem heftigen kultur kampf
wir blicken auf meilensteine der
polnischen geschichte und gegenwart und
fragen warum das land nicht zur ruhe
kommt im demonstrationszug zum
unabhängigkeitstag essmann homophob und
zwar offen
man mag weder muslime noch den
feminismus und hält die
nationalkonservative regierung für
waschler nicht alle hier sind
parteigänger der rechten es gibt auch
unvoreingenommene beobachter seit zum
umsatz ähnlich gegenüber dem gegenüber
größe darum gegenüber washington
und polens seien nicht
selbst wenn ich nicht
ja nicht selbst ein bisschen
ein halbes dutzend organisationen von
rechtsextremisten haben sich zu einer
konföderation zusammengetan und auf
anhieb 7 prozent der wähler hinter sich
versammelt das ist ein problem für die
regierung die eigentlich rechts von sich
nichts entstehen lassen werden das motto
des jahres zeigt ein ritter der mit
seinem schwert einen stern zerschmettert
der stern ist zur hälfte rot und zur
hälfte in regenbogenfarben
wer so denkt sieht sich ständig von
feinden umgeben
von den von der notwendigkeit gesprochen
von den knien aufzustehen
selbstständiges volk zu werden sich vor
fremden mächten zu verteidigen also
immer eine rektorin vielleicht im
neunzehnten jahrhundert oder auch im
kommunismus angebracht gewesen wäre aber
heute eben nicht mehr
eigentlich dürften sich in polen gerade
nur fünf leute versammeln der
bürgermeister er links hat die
demonstration verboten die regierung
drückt ein auge zu ein autokorso als
ausweg die in den autos sind die
besseren demonstranten
da kann man sich wenigstens nicht
anstecken immer wieder müssen die
krankenwagen sich gassen bahn ständig
explodieren knallkörper in dem dicht
gedrängten zug und einige raketen landen
auch im wohnzimmer
die polizei wartet in den seitenstraßen
auf die üblichen steinewerfer viele
beamte so heißt es haben sich krank
gemeldet
und doch ist dieser marsch sagte
langjährige beobachter sowie patrick nur
ein abklatsch seiner selbst die treuen
fußballfans fehlen
es gibt internen krach normalerweise
sind die fußballfans auf seiten der
regierung einigen passt aber die
richtung nicht
das neue abtreibungsverbot spaltet die
fußballfans und deshalb sind
möglicherweise einige zu hause geblieben
simo wird ist als eher linker
schriftsteller von anfang an dabei und
so weiß er dass der nationalismus seine
grenzen hat das lustige ist dass sie
nach dem unabhängigkeits marsch
gemeinsam einen döner essen
man würde polen wünschen dass sie ihre
unabhängigkeit eines tages feiern können
als fest der freude und nicht als marsch
ein paar tage zuvor dort wo warschau vor
allem schön und majestätisch ist bekam
die bischöfe abends überraschend besuch
es war bestimmt kein zufall dass die
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten erst
vor das episkopat zogen und sich die
polizei davor in stellung brachte und
danach vor den präsidentenpalast die
kirche und die regierende partei recht
und gerechtigkeit pis bilden eine
allianz und viele glauben dass sie schon
in einem gottesstaat leben wo die kirche
die gesetze macht wenn noch immer denkt
polens wähler sein frommer als dilemma
und katholischer als der papst der war
länger nicht mehr vor ort
ich habe angst dass dies der erste
schritt zu größeren einschränkungen ist
ich habe zwei töchter im teenageralter
und ich will dass sie die wahl haben
es geht ja nicht um wunsch abtreiben
baum soll ich einen toten fötus zur welt
bringen der frauen streik hat in polen
tradition von 2016 gelang es das halbe
land auf die beine zu bringen der rote
blitz ist ihr symbol eine der führenden
köpfe des frauen streiks ist die
juristin und frühere beamten martha
lempert weil sie öffentlich ein megaphon
benutzte hat sie eine anklage wegen
umweltverschmutzung am hals 1 von 40
verfahren
was ist nur los in polen da haben sie
wohl eine kleine revolution angezettelt
warum redet alle welt von einer kleinen
revolution wohl weil wir frauen sind
dabei wollen wir die regierung stürzen
wenn man nur die köpfe zählt dann ist
das liberale weltoffene polen auf dem
vormarsch in warschau waren es
hunderttausende
aber auch in den kleinen orten auf dem
lande dem stammland der regierung gegen
frauen und einige männer
auf die straße hat die pis vielleicht
den anschluss an die junge generation
verloren
jedenfalls an den weiblichen teil fragen
wir einen führenden konservativen
das ist eine wichtige und sehr
gefährliche soziale entwicklung
die junge generation ist sehr gespalten
die jungen frauen gehen nach links und
die jungen männer nach rechts in ein
paar jahren kommt die zeit familien zu
gründen
aber wie soll das gehen wenn sie
weltanschaulich so weit auseinander
es war das oberste verfassungsgericht
das den kulturkampf richtig angefacht
hatte mit einem urteil dass abtreibung
fast unmöglich macht die pis und die
kirchen applaudierten
es gab einigen jubel bei den gruppen von
radikalen abtreibungsgegnern polen
bedeutet das leben wenn wir unsere
kinder nicht umbringen wird polen
wachsen
aber es gab auch andere ernsthafte
fragen fern von jeder polemik wie weit
trägt die fürsorge des staates wenn die
kinder erst mal auf der welt sind und
davor
es ist nicht wahr dass die regierung
sich um die kinder vor der geburt
kümmert das tut sie einfach nicht es ist
enorm schwierig einen termin beim
frauenarzt zu bekommen oder auch nur
informationen gerade jetzt in zeiten der
pandemie wenn frauen von kindern in den
krankenhäusern getrennt werden
niemand kümmert sich um frauen vor oder
nach der geburt sie kümmern sich nur um
den fotos
was zuvor im katholischen kern land
polen und vorstellbar war
es gab protestaktion in kirchen und
schutz staffeln von rechtsextremen vor
der tür mit rückendeckung von ganz oben
wir müssen vor allem unsere polnischen
kirchen verteidigen
wir müssen sie um jeden preis
verteidigen ich rufe alle peace
mitglieder und alle unsere unterstützer
auf die kirchen zu verteidigen
eine straße im norden warschau hier
wohnt jaroslaw kaczynski der mächtigste
mann polens allein mit seiner katze vor
seinem haus patrouillieren polizisten
sie müssen verhindern dass unflätige
schilder an seinem zaun gehängt werden
sonst droht ihnen einen verweis aus dem
fenster schaut sieht er vor allem diese
blitze
das ist überhaupt ein bisschen leer um
ihn herum auch in der politik jahrelang
hatte aber auch dafür gearbeitet er hat
sich isoliert in europa auch in polen
hat er nicht mehr
hat er das gefühl verloren für das was
in diesem land geschieht kaczynski ist
bei den nachbarn nicht unbedingt populär
ich hoffe dass es neue proteste geben
wird dass sie so schnell nicht aufgeben
haben sie teilgenommen
ja natürlich habe ich teilgenommen und
wie war es wo man konnte solidarität
spüren das war sehr schön
[Musik]
die sprüche gegen die pis lassen nichts
an deutlichkeit vermissen
wie zum teufel oder fahr zur hölle hat
man ist höflich formulierend polen am
wendepunkt auch männer sind dabei auch
solche die sich selbst als moderne
konservative bezeichnen
wie der deutsche der seit einigen jahren
hier wohnt seine polnische frau nahm ihn
mit wir müssen dahin gehen ich glaube
das ist ein ganz besonderer moment und
wir bereuen ist dann bin ich da gewesen
sind
das ist eingangs das war doch spürbar
eine bisher nicht da gewesen es gab
vorher proteste eine bisher nicht
dagewesene bisher nicht dagewesene
allgemeine unzufriedenheit eine wut und
ich glaube tatsächlich dieses dieses
update planungsentscheidungen kann hier
der der letzte die letzte entscheidung
gewesen sein in der hinsicht weil
einfach hier die leute dass dessen
überdrüssig sind dass hier ein
funktionierender kompromiss einfach mal
laufen geworfen wird
unsere nächste station ist danzig
frühmorgens im zug durch ein land das
sich unter der pandemie duckt kein
mensch im speisewagen danzig hat
warschau eine erfahrung voraus man weiß
dass worte töten können januar 2009 10
eine stadt nimmt abschied von ihrem
bürgermeister ein meer von kerzen
sie bilden ein herz hier auf der
früheren linien werft ist die
solidarisch geboren und der
bürgermeister stand für diesen teil von
co seine frau magdalena ist nur in die
politik gegangen um gegen den hass zu
kämpfen was genau den attentäter antrieb
was jemand gegen ihren mann haben konnte
pawel adamowicz was er 20 jahren
bürgermeister seine letzten worte sind
auf den gedenkstein gemeißelt danzig ist
großzügig danzig teilt das gute an sich
ist der wundervollste ort der welt
wenige sekunden später kam der anschlag
er stand auf der bühne der größten
polnischen wohltätigkeitsveranstaltung
der countdown lief
alle waren abgelenkt starten in den
himmel
ein vorbestrafter mann drängte sich auf
die bühne und stach mehrmals auf dem
bürgermeister ein
[Musik]
dabei rief ich habe fünf jahre
unschuldig im gefängnis gesessen die
partei des bürgermeisters hat mich
gefoltert
ein gewalttäter im war
magdalena geht auf den wegen die ihr
mann immer nahm
meistens ging er zu fuß ins amt er war
äußerst populär wurde bis zu 70 prozent
der stimmen einige menschen kannten
bereits seine strecke wenn sie etwas
erleben wollten oder einfach kontakt
standen sie beispielsweise an der ampel
und zebrastreifen und sagt lieber herr
bürgermeister und er habe immer
angehalten
ob er feinde hatte sicher war dass er
den machtmenschen der pis regierung im
fernen warschau einen dorn im auge war
weil an ihm in danzig vorbei nichts ging
in der berühmten marienkirche in der die
streikenden arbeiter damals zuflucht und
beistand gefunden haben ist der ruheort
des bürgermeisters magdalena adamovich
vermeidet es an den mörder zu denken sie
sagt sie müsse stark sein für ihre
kinder
was ihm wohl angetrieben hat ich denke
dass er ein werkzeug war das benutzt
wurde im rahmen gewisser mechanismen
mechanismen die in der ganzen welt
funktionierenden deutschland in polen in
russland ein wachsender populismus eine
zynische lust macht auszunutzen
eines der größten projekte des
bürgermeisters was an die aufstände der
werftarbeiter zu erinnern und ein ort
des dialogs an die stätte der
untergegangenen werk zu bauen
das european center of solidarity im
zweiten stock residiert lech walesa das
klima zwischen ps und den soli davos
zentrum ist so schlecht dass die
regierung noch nicht mal zum geburtstag
gratuliert niemand kann das so drastisch
kommentieren wie der hausherr
friedensnobelpreisträger und präsident
hd kämpfe gegen sie sogar mit meinen t
shirt mit dem was draufsteht verfassung
jeden tag tragen weil sie die verfassung
missachte und das kann ich nicht
zulassen dass in populisten das sind
kleine leute aber sehr frech mit den
alten herren und weggefährten wie verona
und kaczynski auf beiden seiten gibt es
keine versöhnung
und ob sich die jungen frauen und männer
zusammen raufen können polen steht
wieder einmal vor einer wende
bei allem streit und bei aller
uneinigkeit in polen auf zwei dinge
können sich die meisten polen einigen
das eine ist solidarisch der
werftarbeiter streik 1980 lange vor dem
fall der berliner mauer und das zweite
ist wenn sie auf die nachbarn im westen
gucken viele polen sind der meinung und
es werden immer mehr
dass deutschland da ein bisschen zu
billig davon gekommen ist
so sahen die mitte von warschau 1945
nach dem krieg aus sechs jahre lang
hatten deutsche truppen das land besetzt
sie waren gekommen nicht um zu siegen
sondern zu vernichten
nur ein einsamer kirchturm ragte aus
meter hohen schutz ghetto von warschau
etwa ließen sie keinen stein auf dem
anderen die um ihre schande vergessen zu
machen wollen als staat sollte
verschwinden fast wäre ihnen das
gelungen
es handelte sich nicht um militärisch
schüler ist dient nicht darum jetzt
ordnung in der stadt zu schaffen so wie
es ging darum diese stadt auszulöschen
doch die besetzer hatten die rechnung
ohne die polen gemacht kaum waren die
besatzer weg kam sie langsam ans licht
[Musik]
maria schoo stoffe und sophia schor mit
tosca waren mittendrin die beiden
fotografinnen bahnten sich den weg durch
die altstadt von warschau kletterten
über die trümmer des ghettos passten auf
dass sie nicht verschütt ging mit der
kamera machen sie inventur
sie hielten fest was fehlte und was noch
da war den fahrradladen unter freiem
himmel
das fotogeschäft in einem ausgebrannten
straßenbahn wirkung die ersten straßen
märkte mit neuen kartoffeln schön
anzusehen aber fast unbezahlbar teuer
eines ihrer lieblingsmotive war der
erste schönheitssalon und sollte
warschau auch in trümmern liegen so
konnte man herauslesen
die frauen der stadt kam schnell wieder
auf die beine diese bilder prägen bis
heute das denken der polin die polen
denken an deutschland zu eröffnen indem
kriegs perspektive das muss man doch
deutlich sagen wenn ein pole deutschland
die deutschen hört da sagt er zuerst
kriegsverbrecher hitler
konzentrationslager otto hofmann ist
kein besonders religiöser mann aber auf
dem weg zu diesen stufen werden alle
still
er fragt dem alten jüdischen brauch und
legt einen stein am mahnmal im
warschauer ghetto
früher war das sinnvoll um die wilden
tiere von den gräbern abzuhalten
hoffmann ist einer von 20.000 polnischen
juden von 1 3 millionen
seine familie hat den holocaust in der
sowjetunion überlebt hier hatte seinen
echten aufstand gegen die nazis gegeben
aus wut und verzweiflung mit
hunderttausenden von toten und niemand
kam zur hilfe
die deutschen haben entschädigung für
israel gezahlt und nun meint nur die
jüngere generation das reicht und
ansonsten schuldeten sie niemand etwas
schon gar nicht den juden und den polen
und vor allem nicht in polnischen juden
vor 50 jahren ging hier ein mann in die
knie
der schon damals wusste dass man vor
seiner schuld nicht weglaufen kann und
wer war besser dafür geeignet als er
der ist eigentlich nicht nötig hatte
willy brandt der deutsche bundeskanzler
hatte niemanden eingeweiht auch seine
engsten berater nicht
[Musik]
näherkommen registrierten wie es wurde
plötzlich mucksmäuschenstill
für die juden in der welt und nicht nur
für sie kam diese geste wie eine
erlösung juden wussten
selbstverständlich dass willy brandt
nach norwegen gegangen war und sich dem
widerstand angeschlossen hatte brand das
war ein guter deutscher forschung
der abstecher zum ghetto war nicht
geplant stand nicht im protokoll
willy brandt war auf staatsbesuch in der
damaligen volksrepublik polen auf dem
besuch im ehemaligen ghetto hatte willy
brandt persönlich gedrängt keiner der
gastgeber sprach ihn darauf an
es herrschte betretenes schweigen konnte
dann lässt sich nicht anderes tun als
zeichen zu setzen ich bitte als einer
der nun nicht zu den wildesten am engen
hätten es gehört hat um es mal so zu
sagen ich bitte für mein volk und welt
sein bete auch darum dass man uns
verzeihen will der damalige
außenminister walter scheel der ihn
begleitete erinnert sich wer hat mit
dieser symbole handlung für das ansehen
der deutschen der welt mehr getan als
viele regierungen insgesamt mit ihrem
mit ihrem guten willen und ihrer guten
politik bewirkt habe brandt war gekommen
um den polen die angst vor deutschen
gebietsansprüchen zu nehmen seine neue
ostpolitik verzichtete auf ehemals
deutsche gebiete brand hatte zu hause
die vertriebenen die im verrat vorwarfen
polen war nach 1945 wieder mal spielball
der großen mächte das land wurde um
hunderte kilometer nach westen
verschoben
die schraffierten flächen im osten
musste es an russland abgeben die
schraffierten flächen im westen
ostpreußen pommern und schlesien bekam
polen als ausgleich zig millionen
menschen mussten ihre koffer packen
die grenzen sollten nun 25 jahre nach
kriegsende vertraglich gesichert werden
damals wurden die verträge über die
endgültige westgrenze polens entlang von
oder und neiße und attacken
das war sehr wichtig für den platz
polens und deutschlands in europa und es
ging fast schon wieder zivilisiert zu
das schicksal der polnischen juden war
offiziell kein thema in warschau 1970
die wunden waren noch zu frisch
einer der wenigen überlebenden erinnerte
sich dankbar an brandts geste das neue
deutschland hatte sich endlich zu seiner
verantwortung bekannt
brand auf dem gebiet des ehemaligen des
warschauer ghettos und zwar genau auf
dem platz auf dem zaun mein leben und
meiner frau entschieden hat da sind wir
raus geführt wurden da wurden wir auf
geführt konnte wir wussten noch nicht
nach links das heißt zum umschlagplatz
und vor vergasen oder nach rechts dann
durften wir noch etwas am leben bleiben
mehr als eine halbe million menschen
wurden hier zusammengepfercht die eine
hälfte starb die andere später in den
gaskammern
wir wissen heute dass sie zu leicht
davon gekommen dass die deutschen nicht
genug bestraft worden für all das was
sie gemacht haben
besonders in diesem teil europas dieses
gefühl dass deutschland zu billig davon
gekommen ist sitzt tief die
nationalkonservative regierung peace
west seit jahren rechnen und rechnen
da kommt schnell eine billion euro
zusammen warschau sieht auf den ersten
blick nicht so aus wie eine stadt die
reparationen nötig hätte eine sehr
moderne stadt und entsprechend zieht es
zwischen den wolkenkratzern
die züge sind pünktlich der import liegt
bei 250 milliarden dollar im jahr
der export auch wer jetzt noch von polen
wirtschaft also chaos und mängeln
spricht macht sich lächerlich oder war
länger nicht mehr da mit dem wohlstand
kommen andere sorgen wo es brot genug
gibt soll es auch gerecht zu polen hat
sechs millionen menschen verloren
warum wissen nur wenige in der welt vom
leid der polin wurde ihre sache nicht
gut verfochten oder wollte es niemand
hören
es gibt kaum einen kilometer entfernt
vom ehrenmal der juden ein ort der lehrt
dass man große verbrechen verschweigen
kann aber nicht auf dauer als die
polnische autorin monika zeretzke ein
kind war
waren dies
helden unperson kein wort habe sie in
der schule von den helden des warschauer
aufstands gehört das war zu den
kommunistischen zeiten undenkbar
das wäre undenkbar gewesen dass so ein
denkmal entsteht weil die landes armee
die den aufstand organisierter sehr
antikommunistisch eingestellt wurden
willy brandt hätte die rebellion des
bürgerlichen polens also gar nicht ehren
können das denkmal gab es 1970 noch
nicht auch dieser aufstand ging verloren
heldenhaft und hoffnungslos auch hier
kam niemand zu hilfe
die sowjetarmee stand schon am anderen
ufer der weichsel griff aber nicht ein
unter denen aber auch solche leute die
auf die hilfe der russen die auf der
anderen seite der wechsel standen
gehofft hatten die russen kamen nicht
mit der hilfe die russen ließen also im
polnischen bewusstsein ist es so
verankert
die russen ließen eigentlich diesen
aufstand die deutschen eigentlich diesen
aufstand und ganz warschau einfach
zerstören kaputtmachen polen also wieder
opfer wie schon so oft
beim wiederaufbau der wechselbrücke auf
sich allein gestellt und die nächste
enttäuschung stand bevor der große
bruder sagte die entschädigung des
westens ein
aber eigentlich ist sind die russen uns
dieses reparationen schuldig weil sie
uns weil die reparationen an polen
gingen an moskau und das waren so
vereinbart dass die russen uns ein teil
von den ganzen reparationen wie sie von
deutschland bekommen zurückgeben und das
haben sie natürlich nie gemacht also die
russen haben uns betrogen
in dem sinne
die polin schafften es aus eigener kraft
die altstadt aufzubauen
das dauerte bis mitte der 60er jahre das
know-how machte sie zu begehrten
experten für den wiederaufbau auch
außerhalb polens
wer sich fragt warum die altstadt fast
wie eine filmkulisse aussieht findet sie
in der vergangenheit vielen älteren
polen blieb der mund versiegelt wenn sie
an die zeiten der warschauer aufstände
denken etwa der familie von krzysztof
ruchniewicz der als historiker nun all
das zusammenträgt was mutter und
großmutter zeitlebens nicht in worte
fassen konnten das kind damals konnte
sie sich nur an die grünen erinnern
sie konnte sich nur an glatten rhynern
ruchniewicz beschäftigt sich als
wissenschaftler mit der frage der
reparation es ist ein langer streit
schon von der brand regierung forderte
man summen mit sehr vielen nullen
der historiker sagt deutschland hat etwa
drei milliarden gezahlt das sei genug
die forderung der polnischen regierung
nach reparationen ist heute passiert wir
haben keinen anspruch mehr auf die
operationen auf der suche nach der
angemessenen geste dem richtigen zeichen
landet man irgendwann in berlin
doch mehr sieben jahrzehnte nach
kriegsende gibt es dort keinen platz der
erinnerung das sagt eigentlich alles
wahrscheinlich war es kein würdiges
gefühl wenn die gäste aus polen eben
außerhalb von berlin an den rändern an
einen britischen soldatenfriedhof oder
woanders gedenken mussten
es gab kein denkmal für die opfer in
polen es gibt in berlin mittag ein platz
an dem man würdig gedenken konnte bisher
mansfeld und ihre mitstreiter hatten
erfolg mit ihrer initiative für einen
herausgehobenen platz der erinnerung
oktober 2020 stimmte der bundestag zu
nur die afg enthielt sich
ich denke schon dass deutschland auch
sich damit auseinandersetzen muss dass
der vergangenheitsbewältigung
weltmeister durchaus auch wissenslücken
besaß
und besitzt und in dem man eben gerade
in den deutsch-polnischen und
europäischen dialog sich intensiv mit
diesen geschichtlichen lücken
auseinandersetzt
im bewusstsein gibt man ja gewissermaßen
auch zu dass man bestimmte lehrstellen
noch hatte und dass es sich lohnt sich
diesen zuzuwenden und diese zu fließen
nun beginnt die suche nach einem
geeigneten platz in berlin-mitte wie
etwa dem grundstück in der wilhelmstraße
gegenüber dem finanzministerium das
grundstück gehört dem bund um die trabis
müssten weichen
wie vertrackt das alles ist wir treffen
arthur hoffmann wieder erwartet mit
einer kleinen überraschung auf
der kniefall von warschau ist ein
weltereignis eines der wichtigsten
momente der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte
aber hat es zur deutsch polnischen
versöhnung beigetragen dass brandt vor
dem denkmal der juden kniete hoffmann
hat herausgefunden dass willy brandts
geste im kommunistischen polen fast
totgeschwiegen wurde nur eine einzige
zeitung die jüdische volksstimme druckte
das bild
als mir bewusst wurde dass unsere zeit
um die einzige war
dies veröffentlichte da war mir auch
klar warum das war knapp zwei jahre wird
der antisemitischen hetze nach den
unruhen von 1968 und es war eine geste
die die kommunisten befangen werden sie
wussten nicht was damit anzufangen
kaum ein pole hat den kniefall gesehen
ausgerechnet nach polen hat er kaum
gewirkt die welle des antisemitismus
wurde ganz oben gestartet und breitete
sich dann nach ohne im haus meisten
polnischen juden verließen das land nach
1968 und die treibende kraft des exodus
war genau der herr gomolka der mit willy
brandt die verträge unterzeichnete bei
näherem hinsehen werden die meisten
dinge einfacher bei der deutsch
polnischen geschichte ist das nicht der
fall
vielleicht ist es zeit wieder für eine
solche geste
ob die stätte der erinnerung in berlin
das leisten kann
das käme auf einen versuch machen kurz
hinter der deutsch polnischen grenze
etwas ab vom schuss und radio oder
überquert steht bei swiebodzin ein ganz
besonderes monument es zeigt das an was
das land in schwierigen zeiten immer
zusammen hielt früher jedenfalls dass da
hinter mir das ist der grösste jesus
aller zeiten 50 meter hoch inklusive
hügel
manchmal steht seit ziemlich alleine auf
dem acker aber das mag auch am standort
liegen manche sehen darin ein zeichen
dass die katholische kirche den zenit
ihrer macht bereits überschritten hat
und das in einem land in dem sie
praktisch mal alle hinter sich hatte
das ist polens wichtigste kirche wenn
vielleicht auch nicht die schönste motta
77 war sie fertig eine arche im roten
meer arche wie schiff rot wie
kommunismus kommunisten mögen eigentlich
keine kirchen das sei opium für das volk
es gab nur ein problem viele im volk
wollten partout eine kirche und dafür
schufteten sie zehn jahre lang ohne lohn
nachfeier der jüngste bauhelfer war
voltec nowak ich war gerade sechs jahre
alt
da war der damalige pfarrer die
mitglieder der gemeinde
jeder der von den ferien zurück kommt
bringe bitte eine tasche mit den steinen
vom fluss runde glatte der formen wie
die sie viele kind viele familien haben
diese steine mitgebracht aus denen
später die fassade dieser kirche gebaut
vor der kirche hält johannes paul der
zweite wacht es ist schließlich seine
kirche genau hier sollte sich stehen da
wo es die macht habe auf keinen fall
wollten und er hatte die volksnähe die
den regierenden offenbar abging
schwieriger bürger
er kam einfach zur baustelle um zu
fragen wie es geht
was ist neu die gerüste hinauf
und er sprach mit allem den arbeitern
mit dem ingenieur mit dem fall in der
zehnjährigen bauphase der kirche von
nova huta predigte karol wojtyla so sein
bürgerlicher name jeden weihnachten
unter freiem himmel auch den ersten
spatenstich führte er aus
[Musik]
die behörden hatten allen staatlichen
unternehmen verboten
für den bau der kirche trainer horst zu
lang deshalb musste man diese über 20
meter hohen mauern mit der hand also in
beton der hand hoch schaut eine schaufel
nachdem man kann sich vorstellen wie
viele menschen es gebraucht hat um diese
gigantischen wende zu betonieren
am ende kam das geld für das baumaterial
von katholiken im westen und die
baustoffe wurden unter der hand in polen
produziert hier spielte sich die zukunft
unserer kirche in polen ab diese stadt
sollte ohne gott sein nowa huta ist ein
arbeiterstadtteil im osten von krakau
und die kirche das gesellenstück des
karol wojtyla
hier zeigte er wie man zu den
statistischen axenstrasse einen runden
kontrapunkt setzt alle kennen den
polnischen papst als dem mann der kaum
war irgendwo gelandet erst mal die erde
küste
weiße soutane osteuropäischer akzent
wer wollte konnte auch sehen dass der
platz sportlich wann ein skiläufer aus
leidenschaft relativ jung für sein amt
bei seiner wahl noch unter 60 weil er so
viel herum kam 104 reisen sind
überliefert hatte er auch schnell ein
spitz nach eigener vater
tatsächlich brachte er mit einem
einzigen besuch in seinem heimatland das
sozialistisch kommunistische regime zum
wanken
seine worte fürchtet euch nicht wenn ihr
euer leben ändern wollt wirkten wie ein
weckruf zehn millionen menschen kamen um
ihn zu sehen etwa jeder vierte pole
einer stand am wegesrand auch er ein
neuerer und staunte war der papst stark
oder das regime schon so schwach auch
die milizsoldaten machten mit
aber die polizisten konnten den text
nicht wenn sie das kreuz schlugen sie
wir guckten zu und haben nicht mehr an
die zukunft des kommunismus geglaubt das
waren keine echten kommunisten
das war ein bisschen kommunisten außen
rot und innen weiß war wasser der nach
der wende 1990 polnischer präsident
wurde empfängt im europäischen zentrum
der solidarität am hafen von danzig am
alten werft ohr hängt ein bild des
papstes die blumen sind immer frisch
1980 sprang gar wasser über den zaun
schloss sich den streikenden arbeitern
der lenin-werft an und wurde schnell zum
anführer
was sie alle bewegte die normen waren zu
hoch die arbeit zu gefährlich die läden
zu leer die menschen verbrachten einen
großen teil ihres lebens mit schlange
stehen arbeiterproteste hat es in polen
viele gegeben neu war dass die
unzufriedenen nun den papst auf ihrer
seite hatten
natürlich hat der papst eine große rolle
gespielt aber und der revolution hat er
nicht gemacht
1979 gab es noch keine organisation in
einem jahr im video leute zu
organisieren in diesem saal ging die
sozialistisch kommunistische regierung
in die knie
nach 18 tagen ausstand bei vanessa war
im kreis der funktionäre der einzige
ohne schlips und ohne parteibuch aber
mit nerven wie kein anderer und
unterzeichnete die einigung mit dem
symbolhaften stift die einfachen
arbeiter hatten gesiegt im
vermeintlichen arbeiterparadies es war
eine sensation denn die einheitspartei
musste künftig damit leben die macht zu
tal
und noch etwas war ungewöhnlich heiss
war es das ende des streiks verkündete
brach die versammelte weltpresse in
beifall auf erste freie gewerkschaft
mitten im ostblock solidarnosc war
geboren
er war wasser hatten sie keine angst vor
einer sowjetischen invasion in der
damaligen welt hatte ich nur angst vor
dem lieben gott und vor meiner frau ein
bisschen doch dann erklärte das regime
das kriegsrecht am 13 dezember 1981 das
lehrte dann auch was das fürchten
es gab tote panzer fuhren auf und warum
wurde mit tausenden interniert der kurze
sommer der reformen war vorbei auch nur
war uta wurde davon erschüttert zur
marienandacht kamen jedes jahr 20.000
menschen
die militärpolizei umstellte die kirche
hunderte von autos mit bewaffneten
militärs tauchten auf
sie schossen ihre nebelgranaten auch auf
die kirche drang sogar ein um tränengas
zu versprühen
das gas war so stark dass es keine
aushalten konnte einer der den geruch
des tränengases immer noch in der nase
hat ist der krakauer dokumentarfilmer
augustine damals ein junger mann mitten
im geschehen
es gab auch leider eine besonders
tragisch war das schicksal des jungen
boxer jahre offizier der geheimpolizei
der dokumentarfilmer erinnert sich noch
an die brutale gewalt und es heute noch
froh dass er in nowa huta an die
richtigen menschen geriet ich klopfte in
diesen plattenbauten bei wildfremden
leuten an und fragte ob sie meine kamera
seine filme für mich aufbewahren würden
bis die luft wieder rein sei
ein tag später kam ich wieder meinen
kaffee oder tee
kein problem niemand hatte mich
denunziert oder mein material
vier jahre später 1983 kam der papst
noch mal nach polizist überall
kommentierte die polen korrespondentin
des schwedischen fernsehens die
besonders nah am geschehen waren überall
miliz in jedem bus in jedem auto ständig
wird man kontrolliert es ist unmöglich
zu schätzen so notierte sie wie viele
zusätzliche polizisten im einsatz waren
offiziell 6000 aber es könnten auch
zehnmal so viel sein
50 oder 60 tausend viele sind jung und
nervös teile von warschau sind
abgeriegelt alle straßen sind blockiert
die busse müssen außerhalb abgestellt
werden die gläubigen dürfen nur zu fuß
in die innenstadt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die stimmung in warschau ist gespannt
aber auch voll freudiger erwartung vor
der st anna kirche stehen gruppen von
menschen und singen abend für abend es
werden immer mehr
ebenso wie die blumen und kränze für
inhaftierte oppositionelle und bilder
von lexar und den papst irgendwann war
es auch die polizei leid die grenze für
den papst beiseite zu schaffen
als johannes paul der zweite dann in
seiner heimatstadt krakau predigte
gelang piotta augustin eck sein
meisterstück als fotograf eine million
menschen
das staatliche fernsehen übertrug zwei
stunden lang die reden des papstes
sparte aber die massen szenen aus
das wurde erregte großes aufsehen und
kostete august die nec seine stelle beim
staatlichen fernsehen
nachdem ich dieses foto in einer kleinen
katholischen oppositionszeitung
veröffentlicht hatte nach langem
hickhack mitte zensur um den richtigen
bildausschnitt wurde ich beim start
sender tvp entlassen
angeblich weil man zwei programme für
ein paar monate aussetzen wollte wo wir
unsere kunden sich gleichzeitig von
unbequemen mitarbeitern trennen diese
zeitung wusste auch dass der papst am 23
juni 1983 noch zeit für lech walesa fand
vier stunden lang und das stärkte dem
gewerkschafter den rücken
es wurde eher allgemein gesprochen
wir mussten aufpassen wir wurden ja
abgehört und wollten unsere
informationen und pläne nicht preisgeben
ob die beiden damals schon ahnten dass
polen einmal zur europäischen union
gehören würde
ein sonntag in der arche zu zeiten von
kona nur 49 menschen sind zugelassen
man sitzt mit weitem abstand wenn die
korona pandemie eines tages geschichte
ist strömen sie wieder sowie an dem
regentag als karol wojtyla die kirche
einheit acht messen jeden sonntag zählt
der fahrer 5500 teilnehmer und in nowa
huta gibt es noch ein dutzend weiterer
kirchen polen hat den ruf das
katholische land europas zu sein obwohl
auch hier die neigung zum kirchgang
rückläufig ist die die da kommen mögen
eine besonders fromme minderheit sein
aber sie sprechen für eine mehrheit des
wahlvolkes natürlich gibt es in der
kirche platz für alle auch für frauen
doch nicht als fahrer ich glaube nicht
dass es eine berufung für frauen ist die
keuschheit vor der ehe sollte erhalten
bleiben
die eheleute sollten auch erst nach der
heirat zusammenwohnen vor der heirat
sollten sie separat leben und erst nach
der heirat zusammen
wir sagen jetzt gar nicht ist dass die
freiheit die johannes paul der zweite
meinte wie es ist der kirche bekommen
dass sie mit am tisch der macht sitzt
manche sagen nach der vollen macht
strebt der wohl bekannteste
kirchenkritiker der exit und
theologieprofessor stan oberbeck sieht
polen unter der fuchtel der kirche sehr
zum schaden der toleranz
offiziell gibt es die trennung von
kirche und politik
aber wenn man sieht wie die politik von
links bis rechts sich auf die kirche
einlässt dann habe ich gar keine zweifel
wir sind noch nicht in modernen zeiten
angewandt in polen ist in wahrheit ein
gottesstaat
in nowa huta trond jedenfalls der fahrer
von einem neuen leitstern eine art
erlösung war durch puffern wir brauchen
wieder eine solche charismatische
führungspersönlichkeit wie johannes paul
den zweiten sehr darauf dass sich eine
solche figur eine solche person offenbar
aber geht das gut zusammen demokratie
und erlöser der freiheit bekommt es
offenbar besser denn niemand auch die
kirche nicht allein das sagen hat in
nova huta endet unsere reise entlang der
meilensteine der geschichte werden
erfahren wie wenig von polen nach 1945
noch übrig war
welche rechnungen aus dem weltkrieg noch
offen sind und warum die großen nachbarn
vom leiter polen so wenig wissen wollen
wie der polnische papst millionen von
menschen wieder auf die knie und den
kommunismus mit ins wanken brachte bis
am ende die mauer und warum das land
heute nicht zurück
[Musik]